does artificial intelligence excite or
scare you now of course they're great
science fiction stories where the robots
with their artificial intelligence
take over the world
oh ah still fresh for me every time
greetings bill nye here answering your
questions from twitter this is yet
another science support
[Music]
at yes on 522 hand isn't evolution just
a theory that remains unproven no
evolution is a theory that has been
proven over and over
and i remind you the word theory in
science is does not refer to something
that you just make up like an idea the
word theory in science means something
that with which you can make predictions
countless predictions like covet 19
mutating into all these variants
countless predictions have been made
with the theory of evolution evolution
is the fact of life and it's why you and
i are here but it is my wish that you
will think about that evolution is what
makes the whole thing go at steelhester
ask this morning's group chat subject
weight comma what do brains actually
feel like well if you go into medicine
they'll let you squeeze a brain i've
squeezed a few brains
look i'm fine they're firm but squishy
they're squishy but firm
here's a question from an at enterobang
underscore two will humanity ever leave
the solar system probably not but some
future species maybe you know humanity
may evolve
and change where we couldn't breed with
ourselves that species may leave the
solar system not sure where they would
go or what they do but we might send an
instrument a spacecraft to another star
system i could imagine that easily
we'd use a solar sail and we'd give it a
push with a laser be cool
[Music]
except it'd be in space there wouldn't
be any sound it would just be
well that's that's quite an assertion i
don't know if it's i in there but here
we go question
how do scientists just figure things out
and who is to say what they found is
right what if scientists are just saying
out of their
and we just listen and go with it
because they're scientists you know um
at his milf you're asking a wonderful
and important question this deal of who
is the authority when it comes to
something like
the world is round
you
at first certainly are taking somebody's
word for it the world is wrong because
you go outside you look around the world
looks flat but you can show with a
little diligence that the world is round
and you and i are living at a time when
we can look at pictures from spacecraft
when it comes to climate change
that's a lot harder you're taking the
word of climate scientists largely
albeit until recently when the fires are
getting worse and worse and everything's
getting warmer and warmer but there
you're really taking somebody's word for
it but what we want
this milf
is for you to be able to evaluate the
claims of the scientists and so this is
why we want science education for
everyone
at tony basi4 will artificial
intelligence have the capability of
knowing it is a.i and was created by
pound sign humans do we know whether we
are an advanced bio ai think about it
we're probably not an advanced ai you
know in science you're not allowed to
have what's called an
unfalsifiable hypothesis that's not
useful in science so if you have a
hypothesis that we are part of a video
game or an artificial intelligence
system and we can't know it that's not a
useful hypothesis you can't know it
because the the artificial intelligence
programmed it so you can't know it well
what if i found a way to find the
artificial well they programmed it so
you would think you found it but you
didn't really find it's just it's a
circle you'll never get there from here
good question though excellent question
buffy summer summer i'm not an astrology
girly well we have that in common but
every time weird hickory is going on in
my life it's mercury retrograde can
science explain that yes
now here's what's happening the orbit of
mercury is only 88 earth days so the
earth is going around mercury's going
around and so as observed from earth
mercury appears to move backwards in the
astronomical night sky
but it happens all the time with a
period of only 88 days it's just the
chances of you looking at mercury when
it happens to be appearing to be going
backwards relative to fixed stars is so
often you're just conflating or mixing
cause and effect stop
attributing anything in your life to
astrology it is utter bunk as my mother
always said
common sense is not that common
at alex g2 how does climate change cause
pandemics
do we globally come down with colds when
it freezes in night sweats when it thaws
if you're a human what is the most
dangerous animal out to get you
it is not as you might expect as dorothy
expected lions and tigers and bears oh
no mosquitoes are the most dangerous
animal for humans so as we enable
tropical organisms to live farther and
farther from the equator the chances of
us getting infected are higher and
higher then with our technological
success that has enabled us to have
airplanes that fly all over the place we
have now transmitted diseases from one
person to another much more readily than
was possible 200 years ago and so this
is a drag but it's also an opportunity
because we understand what's happening
at purple can i you know sometimes i
wonder are humans still evolving or have
we somehow halted or altered nature's
process of natural selection no we're
still evolving man the mate you select
is
based on evolution if germs and
parasites can kill you then you don't
live as long and you're much less likely
to pass your genes on but then it gets
into this other bigger thing is it not
just the individual but is it the
society or culture that produces them
uncle bill predicts as women and girls
become more enabled in our societies
they're able to live longer get jobs
have their own credit cards then they're
waiting longer to have kids and so i
think we are very subtly selecting at
least in the developed world for women
who are able more successfully to have
babies later well stay tuned over the
next few centuries we'll see if that
proves to be
true it's a hypothesis you can evaluate
it at crypto rises to moon asks how do
scientists determine temps i guess
that's temperatures from thousands of
years ago
serious question well of course it's a
serious question so geologists look at
the minerals that form so if you've got
lava you have molten rock and it cools
off it'll trap certain minerals certain
patterns of atoms and molecules by
melting lava in the laboratory they can
determine what minerals form and then
work backwards from there
and then the other thing if you find
plants and animals in
in the geologic formation and you know
that those plants and animals could only
thrive when it was warm then you can
infer that that layer of rock formed
when it was warm and you go to
antarctica and there's fossil dinosaurs
down there because they were able to
wander around not when it was covered
with ice but when it was covered with
lush things to eat you know
dinosaur salad
and i hope it was fun for them at wild
spartans
why are hurricanes and typhoons called
different things when they're basically
the same thing
they're coined by uh different people in
different parts of the world speaking
different languages
you know
what are you supposed to do you grew up
speaking french you're gonna say one
thing you grow up speaking tagalog
you're going to say another thing in
general
hurricanes occur in the northern
hemisphere so they're spinning
counterclockwise many many typhoons
occur in the southern hemisphere and
they'll be spinning clockwise here's a
question from bananalyze split how does
the james webb space telescope different
from hubble well jwst as we like to call
it is bigger and more powerful and it
works in the infrared the light it
reflects and gathers is in the infrared
and that's why the mirrors are covered
with gold
real gold because it's just somehow the
ideal material for reflecting infrared
light
chronically tired crees asks if space is
expanding wtf is surrounding space for
it to expand into you've hit upon a
great and wonderful philosophical
question space-time is like
everything it doesn't expand to end
anything everything is just spreading
apart
and what keeps it from spreading apart
near as we can tell are sources of
gravity like stars and planets like
where's it all going into what does this
even mean
put it simply nobody knows
but maybe you'll be the astronomer that
figures it out so it's not expanding any
into anything it is
everything and it's all expanding
whoa
t partane how do scientists determine
when existence will end well i guess it
depends partain what you mean by
existence the solar system you know the
sun four billion years is going to swell
up and
incinerate the earth except as i say
it'll be in space there's no sound it'll
just be
yours and my existence will end a lot
sooner than that
which kind of sucks but that's the way
it is when will there be the end of time
nobody knows but the universe is
expanding and no one really knows why
that is and so since it had a beginning
will it have an end yeah so we'll see no
we won't see neither you nor i we'll see
it sucks
thanks for your question
ben james genuine question as opposed to
the questions that he might normally ask
how do scientists tell the difference
between covet variants what makes them
different from each other other than the
effects of humans i'd love to know the
answer it doesn't appear there is any
type of universal rules or standards oh
contraire ben james we have developed
techniques for determining the sequence
of amino acids on
dna and they can tell when the sequence
changes so that's where the word variant
comes from now evolution is this process
by which living things make replicas of
themselves and so when they make copies
there are little changes introduced and
because there's so many millions of us
infected with so many billions of these
viruses these changes are emerging
naturally especially fast
stay tuned there will be new variants
this fall
coach bj thompson bj116
does artificial intelligence excite or
scare you it excites me artificial
intelligence is just the next thing in
computing you make software that uses
what it did before to make a better
version of itself and this gets into an
old thing called feedback and control at
some level you know you have a
thermostat you introduce changes based
on what happened before people are
opening the doors and letting the heat
out or the air-conditioned air out at
certain times of day the thermostat will
compensate for that and bear in mind
humans design all this stuff this
doesn't come out of the sky these are
people designing systems and so if we
make a system that gets out of hand and
crashes well that's bad so we'll have to
change it so it doesn't do that
it's going to be exciting
jiggy summer asks how do scientists
figure out where life can exist in the u
and i don't think they mean the
university because that's also a mystery
we just launched the jwst james james
webb space telescope one of the things
we're going to try to do with this gizmo
is look for methane in atmospheres of
distant distant distant planets
so there are non-organism ways to make
methane but most here on earth comes
from living things from bacteria that
give it off when cows are burping those
are bacteria in their tummies that are
producing this stuff and so if we see
methane in the atmosphere of a distant
planet
one might infer that there's something
alive over there and then the big
other big thing is as near as anybody
can tell to have living things you need
a way to move chemicals around you've
got to have a liquid
that would dissolve chemicals move them
around allow the chemicals to come back
out of solution and be used by this
living thing the overwhelming
likely candidate is water and there is
water all over our solar system on icy
asteroids and other planets and so we
figure there must be water out there and
if there's water out there and it is
also a solvent for other living things
then perhaps very reasonably there are
other living things note well that is
very reasonable that you and maybe even
i will be alive when life is discovered
on another world and when that happens
it will change this world all of us will
feel differently about being a living
thing
in the cosmos
atds asks why is genetic engineering so
complicated
mush brain not understand genetic
engineering is either simple or really
complicated so guys like george
washington thomas jefferson take the
pollen from one wheat plant and shake it
onto the ova the eggs of another wheat
plant to hybridize them
so that was genetic modification
by traditional farming farmers have been
messing with plants and crops and
domesticated animals for centuries 10
000 years at least but doing it in much
more subtle quicker more effective ways
requires understanding the genome
of corn or whatever you're trying to
mess with
and then understanding a mechanism that
keeps the corn borer from this is an
insect from eating it then had to put
that gene
into corn
not so easy but it was done and by the
way that whole genetic modification
thing started with cotton and then the
other famous famous thing is this
business with glyphosate the big brand
name you hear about is roundup they
figured out there's this chicamic acid
pathway oh yes
by inhibiting the plant's ability to
metabolize the chakimic acid they could
put this material on the crops on the
ground weeds couldn't grow things that
grow fast couldn't grow
but then of what's happened in the great
evolutionary arms race of life
species of weed are emerging where the
the shikimic acid pathway is not
inhibited and they grow anyway it's us
versus them
and i remind us
farming is not natural if you stop
farming the land goes back to a prairie
or a forest or meadow whatever it was
it's humans doing this stuff that
enables us
to eat
when i was young
there were fewer than 3 billion people
in the world now they're almost 8
billion and that's because we found ways
to feed them all and a lot of that has
been genetic manipulation of crops good
question dev does drawings wants to know
why does co2 get all the hate when it's
methane that causes more damage to
global warming why is no one talking
about cutting those emissions people
talk about methane all the time people
are very very concerned about methane
methane leaks at oil wells and oil
production methane leaks is a huge
problem cow burps cal burps
are a huge problem but the reason you
hear so much about co2 is because
there's so much more of it the effect of
co2 is bigger than the effect of methane
both enormous problems for us humans at
therapy how do droughts work like does
the rain cycle just decide to stop
working let us keep in mind the rain
cycle does not as we say have agency i
don't think it makes any decisions just
as we make the ocean out here warmer
the air coming ashore is drier as this
gets drier everything gets drier more
droughts are making things drier which
causes more droughts
at dear sarah
how do volcanoes erupt after doing
nothing for decades this is a real
question like wtf caused an eruption to
happen the movement of tectonic plates
happen over tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of years so 10
years in the volcanic tectonic scheme of
things is a tiny tiny fraction so these
little shifts in the tectonic plates
cause volcanoes to happen and on human
time scales they seem far apart but on
geologic time scales they're just
happening all the time at devon04522082
asks how many millions of gallons of
water can a hurricane drop
i think it's closer to billions so
we've done calculations on katrina and
then there are category six hurricanes
so far they've only happened at sea but
they drop
millions and millions of tons of water
so if this desk were full of water two
of these desks were full of water it
would weigh about a ton millions of tons
of water billions of gallons
so those are all the questions for today
thanks for watching science support this
has been part four and i hope you felt
that your science was supported thanks
for watching let's change the world